i'm curious about the ending and if you
shot anything else
to go with the way it was or was it
always envisioned with a certain
character walking out the door
i'm just curious if you shot with
another character also walking out the
door well it's a
it's a very good point we tested two
endings
on the film one is the one you see
okay
and the other is
you don't see who
so as the door start as the door starts
to open
um
so you cut away so you never know
right
that was the other one and
we tested the film the tests are very
high and
uh the audience loved the one you see in
the
in the movie as it stands now
uh was it a really big difference of a
score or it was it probably about seven
points something like that eight points
and what's so interesting is it wasn't
just the ending
that
affected other things as well in other
comments if you see what i mean and and
so it wasn't just the ending that came
up it was other elements as well came up
because that was the ending it's quite
interesting the interesting thing about
movies nowadays is that everything has
to be thought about
as to whether or not if it's a hit if
you want to make another one you know
like hitman's bodyguard i don't they
never intended to make a sequel and all
of a sudden you know it was a huge hit
yeah
absolutely well i mean you know that
they and and uh who knows i mean it's uh
there were no there's been no talks of
sequels with this simply because we just
made the movie it was a one-off
basically
so
you know it is what it is